hallo und herzlich willkommen hier aus
der maria theresien kaserne in wien
wir sind heute für euch da donnerstag
der 28 die erste mit einem fitness am
arbeitsplatz workout gestern war ein
hartes militärisches boxen box workout
mit omas am kopf nummer 16 der welt im
boxsport heute sah man wie gesagt
fitness am arbeitsplatz intensität geht
runter die übungen kann damit machen
aber heute haben wir wieder einen
spezialgast für euch mit dabei und zwar
die schwimmerin die frau rekrut marlene
carla eine parade athletin aus dem
schwimmsport heraus olympia
qualifikation geschafft das heißt mitten
in der olympia-vorbereitung auch aber
marlene am besten du stellst du kurz
selbst vor marlene karla ich bin 19
jahre alt ich schön in der südstadt
jetzt schon fast mein halbes leben lang
und habe mich eben 2009 10 mehr als für
die olympischen spiele qualifiziert und
bin zu dem österreichische
rekordhalterin auf meinen längeren
strecken und 2018 bei den jugend
olympischen spielen war also bessere
voraussetzungen kann man nicht haben
entsprechend wären heute fitness am
arbeitsplatz mit dir glaube ich ganz gut
umsetzen können das heißt wir fahren am
besten an ein lockeres mobilisieren des
gesamten körpers das heißt ohne
großartig zum schwitzen zu beginnen
sollte dieses werk hat jeder mitmachen
können also wie man es wirklich jeder
also vom anzugträger angefangen
alle können das machen ohne irgendein
problem zu haben um wird vorschlagen
wir beginnen beim sprunggelenk das heißt
sprunggelenk kreisen beginn war klar am
boden dass man mal ein bisschen schwung
kommen und die richtung wechseln seite
wechseln
und jetzt jetzt wir haben zwischen
drinnen da ein mobiles büro sozusagen
aufgebaut wo man wirklich auch sehr
authentisch die übungen beibringen zu
können okay wächst und dann noch einmal
die seite heben das knie an und kreisen
klassen kniegelenk heraus nochmal gleich
gleichgewicht der bislang aktivierung
auch mit dabei seit man schlimmste ich
habe schon ein kleines baby in der zeit
begonnen wenn aber leistungsmäßig jetzt
knapp 78 jahre also wirklich auf hohem
niveau leute wechseln
zweimal am tag training okay gefühlt
kilometer schwimmt man da täglich ja da
ich langstreckenschwimmer in bin ich
halt leider paar mehr kilometer das
wären dann halt so 14 bis 16 km tag nach
marlies mit zwölf staaten nicht willst
du in der woche sondern die schlimmste
am tag in der woche sind es dann doch
ein paar mehr als wir sind wirklich eben
weil ich meine langen strecken 16
kilometer locker mann aus die beine
ersthelfer plattform ist gleich
gewichtet gestreikt hat ist meine schuld
nehme ich auf mich künftig reisen
nächstes gelenk der mann genau beginnen
mit kleinen kreisen immer größer werden
die kreise dann wenn der kreis am
größten ist wechselt man die richtung
und werden wieder kleiner
erst jetzt irgendwann dann die richtung
wechseln und wieder kleiner werden die
kreise gerne und locker mal raus
verdrehen einmal den oberkörper das
heißt hängender aufgeben oberkörper nach
links und rechts verdrehen
er gehört nehmen wir mal die hände der
schwungmasse mit dazu gibt's eigentlich
seine parade mobilisation übung die
schwimmer sehr gerne und häufig machen
er für uns ist das wichtigste also die
mobile outlook an der schulter ist für
uns das wichtige
deswegen schauen wir das eigentlich
formschön training ca 100 mal die arme
durch gekreist haben haben dass das
einfach alles frei ist weil wir müssen
ziemlich locker seiner schwimmer war
lockerer die schulter desto länger
können wir die züge auch mal alles klar
wir werden es nicht hundertmal kreisen
versprochen aber zumindest zehn mal
vorwärts mal rückwärts oder dass man
bislang gelenkschmiere hersteller dass
man das gelenk bereit machen auf die
belastung die kommt das machen wir mit
euch auch und vorwärts kreisen und die
seite wechseln
und noch mal die richtung wechseln und
auslagern
man lehne eine spezifische mobilisation
übung von dir hier ist eigentlich der
schweizer geiseln als jede übung ok
mobil ist jetzt einen ganz viel ja
handgelenk ist auch wichtig weil wir
sehr viel wasser mit jedem amt zu ziehen
müssen und hätten einmal das handgelenk
gleich dazu also mir imponiert die
mobilisation übung bei den schwimmern
immer wo der oberkörper in der vorbeuge
ist und wo es teure shootern umfasst
weil das ein richtiger reichweite drin
als ich glaube sie berühren sich
teilweise hinten mit den fingerspitzen
also da bin ich weit weg richtung
wechseln
genau ich würde schon machen wir das
gleiche am oberkörper vorlage und hände
aufschwingen und genau nach hinten
zusammengreifen also erkennen da mal
schauen ob mir das zu hause schafft also
bei mir geht sie das beweglichkeit
technik schneider aus die nicht gehört
hat einen oder anderen zentimeter luft
aber man muss man schon einen schwimmer
sein dass man das wirklich so in diesem
bewegungs ausmaß hinkriegt okay aus
lockern als visuelle nick beim schwimmen
ein wichtiger punkt fängst du gerne an
ja nein vielleicht weiß nicht genau ob
wir gehen anfang haben wir durch die
heiß wie visuelle kopfnicken auf und ab
und nach links und nach rechts schauen
und wir kippten den kopf hin und her und
deshalb zu übungen die ihr bei fit am
arbeitsplatz immer machen kann es heute
zu verspannungen im bereich heißt über
seile oder rücken haben heißt über so
alle mobilisieren rücken mobilisieren
oberkörper vertreten dass ein so
klassische übungen die cani immer unter
tage seine einbauen wenn ich bin schon
sehr lang gesessen koma bisschen
bewegung ok locker mal den körper mal
durch das heißt gelenk mäßig bis auf den
album haben wir glaube ich ziemlich
erwischt das heißt letzte übung für den
ellbogen hände seitlich hochgehen und
die arme frau also die arme drehen und
der arme kreisen und generell das werk
etwas mit euch jetzt machen könnte
entweder das gesamte werk hat zwar drei
mal in der woche machen oder auch
auszüge die eine oder andere übung immer
wieder einmal bringen
am tag 23 übungen gemacht und der körper
fühlt sich wohler fühlt sich besser
richtung wechseln
okay wie versprochen es wird nicht
anstrengend werden wir schauen uns aber
die erste übung an die kniebeuge ja die
camper schon aus diversen workshops wie
kann ich dir jetzt im büro umsetzen ohne
dass sie meine hose spreng punkt nummer
eins und punkt nummer zwei dass sie
vielleicht nicht zu schwitzen anfang
mitglied dafür die bitten setzt immerhin
zeige uns einmal variante nummer eins
aus dem sitzen selbst zeigt neben eurem
schreibtisch in unterstützung durch die
rechte hand bei der niki und geht es in
eine einige kniebeuge hoch das ist die
eine variante zweite variante marlene
darf ich dich bitten kann man das erste
tor zurück schieben
wir kennen zwar ohne sessel machen das
heißt er stellt sich einfach neben den
tiefschlaf und geht so weit runter ist
von ihrer beweglichkeit her funktioniert
und drückt sich wieder hoch aber wie
gesagt gleichgewicht unterstützen uns
die hand und wenn es kraft mäßig
notwendig ist kann die natürlich auch
ein bisschen mit rücken arme auslagern
wir machen noch eine mobilisation übung
bevor man in die knie beugen reingehen
das heißt einmal hüfte mobilisieren
linkes knie hoch und nach hinten aus
drehen
das knie hoch leben nach hinten ziehen
genau fünf mal linke seite
mal rechte seite andere seite genau
jetzt positionen einnehmen
30 sekunden ganz grob nehmen uns zeit
und her manier fünf wiederholungen
scharf 25 man szenen markt zum 18
es sieht jetzt aber nicht so sein dass
das workout wird wo man 30 mal auf und
ab springt sondern konzentriert sich auf
das was gemacht konzentriert sich auf
eure beinachse sprunggelenk kniegelenk
hüftgelenk bleibt in einer ebene
das ist es auch was es jetzt ankommt und
was jetzt wichtig ist also 30 sekunden
arbeitszeit und was geht es genau
und jetzt kontrolliert einmal jeder für
sich seine beinachse kontrolliert
langsames aufstehen und wieder hinsetzen
nach zehn sekunden
ok und auslagen 30 sekunden eine seite
haben wir aufstehen aus lockern
ein fortschritt vielleicht im büro auf
und ab geben und dann die seite wechseln
meine damen darf ich bitten dass ihr die
seite wechselt das man nicht dem
publikum dann den rücken zudrehen
damit können sie einfach wieder
entsprechend anhalten auf der richtigen
seite bereit machen und götschl aus den
zweiten 30 sekunden arbeitszeit jetzt
aber sind eine sportliche ziele wo geht
die reise hin ja im sommer im nahe
werden wir hoffentlich bei der em in
budapest starten können okay da wird
sich hoffentlich am final platz sondern
ein weiteres olympia limit ausgehen auf
firma k und großes ziel ist natürlich in
tokio einen finalplatz zustimmen
ok wann genau fliegst du nach tokio
sollte es mit mäßig so funktionieren wie
wir uns das alle wünschen ja das ist
noch nicht ganz sicher
sie wohnt mittlerweile aus kurz
auslagern weil wir davor nach ein paar
wochen zu akklimatisieren okay mit der
zeitumstellung das heißt wir werden
schauen dass wir zwei wochen vielleicht
früher anreisen können dass wir da eben
noch ein kurzes trainingslager als
vorbereitung sprachkurs ausgebucht oder
chinesisch ist sehr schwer das kann man
wahrscheinlich nicht in 14 uhr statt
chinesisch koreanisch 9 14 tage genauso
ist es okay passt ersten hammer dann
mobilisieren einmal für den oberen
bereich für den oberkörper noch einmal
zwischen drinnen
das ist eine übung die jederzeit machbar
ist das heißt ihr gebt eure ellbogen
wieder nach oben schießt die eltern
einmal zweimal zurück und dann öffnet
die arme und zieht es wieder zweimal
zurück eine dynamische bewegung 1234
geschossen weg dass ich eine keine opfer
wobei heute wahrscheinlich nicht so
tragisch gestern beim boxer herz wäre es
wahrscheinlich schmerzvolle ausgefallen
aber braucht man nichts provozieren
90 prozent der tätigkeiten sei es im
büro beim autofahren am handy am pc sind
nach vorne innen orientiert das heißt
die schultern ziehen nach vor eine innen
hinein und bringen mit der in einen
haltungs problem in wahrheit und das ist
eine übung wo aus der mobilisation
heraus in die dynamische dehnung hinein
arbeiten kann den brustmuskel öffnen
kann
um eben da wieder eine ausgleichs
bewegung zu haben und die kennt
definitiv täglich machen
ok ich glaub 30 sekunden hommage nächste
übung was geht man nix das heißt
muskelgruppe oberarme der bahnstrecke
hauptsächlich der trizeps mit dabei da
auch ganz wichtig wenn ihr diese übung
macht entweder am tisch oder am sessel
wenn es sich am sessel markt achtet
natürlich darauf der kann wegrollen
schatz das irgendwo an lens entsprechend
dass dort keine verletzungen passieren
und wichtig bei den jobs ist ihr müsst
das eine aufgerichtete position heraus
arbeiten das heißt wenn man mal in die
startposition gehen marlene lass den mal
in die schultern hineinfallen dass die
leute auch sehen was jetzt nein wenn ihr
diese position nimmt kommt ja auch in
den brustmuskel hinein und dann sah man
genau dort wo man jetzt nicht hin wollen
nämlich nach vorne ihnen zu rotieren
okay das ist schön dass der shooter
herausheben stolzer brust aufrechte
körperhaltung und dann gehen wir in die
dips hinein und dann kann man wirklich
hauptsächlich in den oberarm muskulatur
30 sekunden übung jetzt geht's los
ihr könnt es schwieriger machen indem er
sowie die marlene die beine natürlich
ausstreckt ihr können sie die übung
etwas einfacher gestalten indem er mit
den beinen weiter zurück kommt dann habe
sein weniger langen hebel
dann kennen sie die übung genau so gut
umsetzen ja am sessel am tisch beide
varianten möglich die oberarme werden
trainiert und da die beweglichkeit in
der schulter kann es so bis zu einem
gewissen grad natürlich verbessern ist
das eine übung die schwimmer häufig
markt tipps ja zweimal die woche im ziel
beim grauen des durch drücken der hand
er ist sicherlich keine uninteressante
bewegung so genau so ist es okay dann
wieder auf und aus lockern
oberarme ist das eine der bauch das
andere wir schauen dass man bei den
übungen fit am arbeitsplatz einen ganzen
chor den ganzen körper trainieren die
beine mit den einbeinigen kniebeugen
komma die oberarme einen teil davon
zumindestens haben wir jetzt auch das
heißt wenn man mit dem bauch ford
mitglied sagst du uns einmal eine coole
übung für den brauch die im büro machen
kann genau ist setzt euch einfach auf
einen sessel hin und sie zweimal die
beine an das heißt es man habe schon ex
gute spannung in meiner bauchmuskulatur
marlene kannst natürlich gleich
mitmachen keine frage und aus dieser
position können sie jetzt einmal
wechselweise das bein ein bein aus
strecke dann kriegt schon ganz viel mehr
zug in die bauchmuskulatur und wenn sie
ein bissel mehr haben jetzt streckt
beide beine aus spätestens jetzt müsste
ich aber beim sessel anhalten und das
gleichgewicht nicht zu verlieren und
sieht die gestreckten beinen nach oben
und wieder nach unten sucht sich eine
variante aus die ihr gut umsetzen kann
und ich exakt 30 sekunden arbeitszeit
los geht es natürlich auch möglich dass
nicht immer auf zeit festzuhalten
sondern man kann das auch auf
wiederholungen aufbauen das ist ihm auch
zwölf wiederholungen bauchmuskulatur
oder 15 wiederholungen für meine
bauchmuskulatur
man kann natürlich so auch das werk hat
er bis sie variieren halbzeit hammer
show
fünf sekunden und stoppt aufstehen aus
lockern
jetzt nehmen wir gern noch eine übung
mobilisation auch für den oberkörper nur
mit das heißt am anfang haben wir dieses
auffächern vor der letzten übung gehabt
jetzt machen wir noch mal dass
oberkörper verdrehen das ist ja
entspannenden übungen eine längere zeit
gesessen bin das jedoch entsprechend
wieder ab isla dynamik einig ob er die
hände verschränkt ob es sie mitnehmen
schwungmasse ob sie einfach nur unter
hängen ganz egal was das einfach über
diese rotation in eine entspannung rein
kommt dass die wirbelsäule ein bisschen
durch mobilisiert wird wenn es irgendwo
ist alles in ordnung schmerzhaft sei es
aber nicht sein
ok jetzt haben wir eine muskelgruppe
mehr
das nächste was wir uns anschauen ist
die schulter kreisen bei gott wenn dies
hängt zum beispiel an habe ist es mit
dem arme kreisen oft nicht so einfach
das heißt dass mir nichts dass keine
naht platzt oder sonst irgendwas kann
ich aber genauso die schultern kreisen
das heißt die muss ja nicht die hände
immer strecken sondern kann ja aus der
schulter kreisen und das ist die nächste
option wir kreisen rückwärts mit den
schultern
in großen kreisen das heißt was sie
vorher herausgehört habe man lerne deine
paradedisziplin ist die langstrecke und
dort ist grau okay das ist was wir was
für zeiten schwimmst du wenn du 800
meter schwimmst acht minuten 30 das sind
dann halt auf der langbahn 16 längen ok
und 1500 1032 länge ford vorwärts
kreisen 33 länger auf der kurzbahn
gelang bayer auf der langbahn und 50
meter becken 25 meter becken als auch 50
meter becken brocke aber alle große
ereignisse finden sozusagen immer auf
der langbahn stadt sowie im olympia auch
nicht nur zum auslagern die schultern
also 830 grob auf 800 meter durch die
ganze flotte also
am ausprobieren wenn es das nächste mal
die schwimmbäder offen haben 100 meter
herab gebrochen in der zeit zu schwimmen
ich habe das scheitern nicht nur daran
sondern die masse der bevölkerung oder
gerade schwimmen ist so technisch
anspruchsvoll und das muss man so gut
beherrschen das war der schnelle zeiten
schwimmt also das ist phänomenal und
beeindruckende ok konzentrieren jetzt
greifen wir mal eine schulter vorwärts
und eine rückwärts also dass gegen
gleiche arbeit nach ohne handy das gegen
gleiche arme greifen können wir
natürlich auch mit den shooter machen
also ohne dass man die arme mitnehmen
und die richtung wechseln
und ausland kann wir gehen in die
nächste übung ihr kennt es bereits aus
sämtlichen rumpf kraftübungen und stütz
übungen ja denn unterarm stütz und jetzt
mal eine abgewandelte form die jederzeit
eben wie gesagt im büro nachmachen
können und zwar ist es der liegestütz
rücklings am tisch okay das heißt sessel
auf die seite mit dem gesäß richtung
richtung tisch einmal abstützung sowie
für die dips vorher jetzt nach vorgehen
mit dem beine so dass er in eine gerade
hineinkommt sie weiter nach vor
natürlich desto besser und haltet einmal
die spannung
das erste ist einfach einmal die
spannung zu halten den hintern an zu
spannen und spürt bereits ihr kommen
muskulär in den bereich rückenmuskulatur
rückenstrecke hinein und das ganze kann
jetzt natürlich noch entsprechend
verstärken indem wechselweise meine
beine hoch hebe das heißt erreichen
3 15 cm es kann natürlich auch höher
sein
meine beine vom boden abzuheben nicht
nur um menschen sondern langsam und
kontrolliert das bein im wechsel
hochheben und 30 sekunden arbeitszeit
nochmal jetzt
für dich auch spürbar marlene ja ja also
spüren dass man das gleich ob das jetzt
ein intensives werk wird oder nicht
entscheidet die schräglage des
oberkörpers wem das zu wenig ist kann es
natürlich auch am boden machen
vorgabe war es muss anzug deutlich seien
entsprechend machen was angelehnt am
tisch ok locker mal aus das ganze kann
natürlich auch in der frontansicht
machen
das heißt für die vordere muskel kette
genau so eine übung das heißt auch hier
bitte in die schräglage hineingehen am
tisch abstützen und sekunde im wechsel
grob dass beim hochheben wichtig dabei
becken bleibt gerade kopf ist in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule und mein
körper ist unter spannung
genau nicht gewinnst du in deiner
freizeit wenig okay das heißt du kannst
auch 30 das einordnen was das bedeutet
auf 800 meter aber okay aber es ist
richtig schnell glaubst aber da muss man
kennen da muss man also da braucht man
schon gewisse grundtechnik ja aber wie
gesagt leistungssport schwimmen ist halt
ganz was anderes ja ok aber aus locker
mal durchschütteln
wir haben jetzt ein bissl a stütz kraft
rumpf kraft stütz kraft gemacht vordere
seite hintere seite ok diagonales arm
heben in der vorbeuge glaube ist also
eine bewegung die im schwimmbad von den
profis wenn man oft sehe das heißt die
haben wir gleich kopiert und machen wir
jetzt erklärt zum auslagern aus den
schultern ein bisschen beweglichkeit
arbeiten mobilisieren
genau und da kann natürlich auch mit der
dynamik variieren das heißt wenn ich
ihnen die beweglichkeit ein bisschen
rein arbeiten wie gehe ich mehr nach
oben wenn es nur zu mobilisieren des
gelenks ist reicht im prinzip das
schwingen der arme weil die braucht man
jetzt da wir jetzt da geht es in die
fünfte übung und die fünfte überaus
lockern die fünfte übung
wie immer gesagt haben in jedes
militärische worker topfit am
arbeitsplatz military fitness oder
kraftausdauer es kern liegestütz dazu es
kein buch dazu und die machen jetzt auch
am schreibtisch da sind sie absolut für
jedermann schaffbar also handys stützen
am schreibtisch ab und jetzt geht es mit
dem oberkörper richtung tisch wichtig
wieder eine körperspannung zu haben auch
hier der sprunggelenk kniegelenk hüfte
und schulter und bleiben in einer ebene
biegen sich nicht durch in welche
richtung auch immer
und wie geht es nach oben und nach unten
wie ihr den griff variiert ob ihr bright
greift ob eher schmal greift ist einmal
im ersten satz holzer tragisch wenn ihr
breiter greift kommt mehr in die
brustmuskulatur hinein wenn der spieler
greift mehr in die armmuskulatur in den
trizeps hinein alles gut 30 sekunden die
zwei damen arbeiten schon die ganze zeit
schauen wir mal ob sie noch 30 sekunden
schaffen ihr fangt jetzt am 30 sekunden
liegestütz an der tischkante geht's los
liga ist auch ein ständiger begleiter
marlene oder ein gewisses lernfeld da na
ja leider also ja leider
du magst sie sehr viel ja ok keine
lieblings übung nach aber jetzt hat das
geschafft drei sekunden nur 21 und
auslagern aufpassen keine verletzungen
braucht man keine haben die arme
ausschütteln auslaufen okay wir haben
die liegestütz erledigt sechste übung
wir verlassen unser virtuelles büro wir
gehen an die wand okay aber bevor man
staaten machen wir nur kurzes
mobilisieren das aufrollen der
wirbelsäule
das heißt niki ich darf dich bitten 90
grad zu mir her
marlene du gerade aus wie viel wir wohl
abrollen beginnend bei der
halswirbelsäule beim abrollen und beim
aufräumen dann talenten wirbelsäule
kontrolliert langsam hinein spüren in
den körper genau und wenn man unten
angekommen ist wieder beginnend bei der
lendenwirbelsäule beginnend hoch rollen
brustwirbelsäule bekommen im bereich
halswirbelsäule und dann bei kopf und
das ganze wechsel mal zwei drei mal hin
und her
einmal noch
ok jetzt haben wir noch einmal den fokus
auf die wirbelsäule auf den oberkörper
auf die rückseite gelegt und den
trainieren wir jetzt das heißt wir
marschieren einmal zu unserer mauer in
der trainingshalle ihr nehmt euch
einfach ein frei stück mauer in eurem
büro her
wichtig ist jetzt ihr nehmt es ungefähr
eine schrittlänge abstand mit den beinen
stellt hüftbreit hinlegt solche lehnt
sich an der mauer
das ist einmal gemütliche
ausgangsposition die ellbogen sind 90
grad vom körper weg gespreizt und die
übung besteht jetzt darin dass wir so
stark wie möglich mit den ellbogen in
die mauer hinein drückt das heißt ihr
drückt euch weg von der mauer über die
kraft die ihr aufbringen können mit dem
er den ellbogen in die mauer hinein
drückt das heißt schulterblatt statoren
arbeiten der obere rücken arbeitet er
arbeitet in die aufrichtung hinein um
den haltungsschäden dem nach vorne innen
rotierten entgegenzuwirken perfekte
übung diese bitte auch häufig
wiederholen häufig machen gerade die
unter euch die schwere probleme mit der
beweglichkeit der haben okay aber das
sieht man es ganz deutlich die marlene
als schwimmerin hat eine wahnsinnige
einem wahnsinnigen bewegungsradius was
das betrifft ist es ein must-have
sozusagen beim schwimmen diese
beweglichkeit aus der schulter ja weil
eben wie vor schon gesagt wenn die
schulter die ganze verspannt ist wird
der zug viel kürzer und das ziel ist es
natürlich so viel wasser wie möglich mit
einem zug der bewegung zu vertragen
quasi okay deswegen ist es wichtig dass
wir da locker sind und eben die züge
dadurch länger machen ja mal kurz aus
locker meine damen wird vorschlagen bei
den übungen so wichtig ist manchmal
zweiten durchgang
ja das einmal kurz entspannen aber kurz
auslagern ihr zuhause ist mit dabei wir
machen einen zweiten durchgang noch
einmal ausgangsposition noch mal zehn
wiederholungen ellbogen hoch und er
drückt sich richtig kräftig in die mauer
hinein sodass wir den körper weg gibt
sehr gut nach fünf wiederholungen
spannung grundspannung in der bauch und
rumpfmuskulatur ist natürlich da dass
sie nicht durchhängen das heißt die
schultern bis zum knöchel ist wieder
eine ebene und ich habe geschlossen
quasi den körper weg noch einmal und
auslagen wieder okay wichtige übung
haben wir gesagt jetzt ein zweites mal
gemacht was wir jetzt noch gehen
jetzt haben wir den ganzen körper soll
jetzt einmal von oben bis unten in einer
moderaten art und weise durch trainiert
jetzt schauen wir dass man nur ein
bisschen der beweglichkeit arbeiten und
da fangen wir am besten gern der mauer
an und nehmen die brustmuskulatur her
das heißt beweglichkeit aus dem
brustmuskel heraus einmal die
ausgangsposition hand ist an der mauer
der körper die schuld ab dreht sich hin
und jetzt dreht sie den körper mit
dieser spannung weg tja das heißt noch
zuerst hingehen einrichten und dann den
körper wegdrehen und ihr kriegt in der
brustmuskulatur wirklich schönen zug die
position der hand ist natürlich da
variierbar das heißt ihr könnt die hand
oben greift mitte oder auch tief greifen
der posten muskel ist großer muskel der
unterschiedliche bereiche hat das
experiment viel zeit da ist könne es
unterschiedliche höhen natürlich mit
trainieren als anhalt so 30 sekunden um
die spannung zu lösen ist eine gute
variante ok wechseln gleich seite dass
man beide seiten drinnen haben genau
auch jetzt von der rückansicht gut zu
erkennen die schulter bewegt sich
richtung mauer die hand es an der mauer
und der oberkörper dreht sich weg in die
gegenrichtung so kriege ich einen
optimalen zug in meine brustmuskulatur
hinein
sehen sie konnten ja langsam die
spannung wieder lösen und immer wieder
ins büro tätig sagt eine ganz eine
wichtige übung mal hat man euch nicht
vorenthalten
wenn man für sie jetzt für im auto fort
ja muss ich natürlich meine oberschenkel
rückseite und meine gesäßmuskulatur
entsprechend auch denen das heißt wie
machen wir das am geschicktesten ihr
stellt sich hüftbreit auf genau die
gebiete 90° marlene geradeaus wichtig
ist jetzt der rücken bleibt in der
gesamten bewegung gerade das heißt keine
spannung in der rückenmuskulatur
verlieren und der beuth den oberkörper
so weit nach vorn bisher einen zug im
gesäß oder der oberschenkelrückseite
oder auch der wadenmuskulatur spürt je
nachdem wo die beweglichkeit am meisten
notwendig ist und wenn ihr nicht so weit
kommt wie die zwei damen hier dann ist
das überhaupt kein problem
sobald ihr den zug spürt ist es in
ordnung bleibt in der position versucht
die spannung zu lösen
30 sekunden lang wirklich darauf
konzentrieren dass der zug aus der
muskulatur gelöst wird
und langsam wieder aufrichten auch der
ist weg sagt jederzeit machbar und
natürlich wenn man besitzt ist auch die
halswirbelsäule meistens die die etwas
zu verkürzen etwas die muskulatur im
bereich der a säule verkürzt und
entsprechend belastet ist auch das ist
ein thema was man es noch ganz kurz
anschauen das heißt jetzt die linke hand
nach unten strecken die schulter ganz
tief und den kopf auf die rechte seite
kippen
so komme das seitlich in die muskulatur
wirklich gut hinein
er spürt dass gleich dazu ist gleich da
auch hier versuchen die spannung zu
lösen
doch keine ruckartigen bewegungen machen
ja langsam in die opposition hinein
gehen versuchen die spannung zu lösen
und auch dann langsam wieder heraus
kommen also position wechseln zweiter
seite rechte hand rechte schulter aktiv
und dieter kopf auf die linke seite
vorbereitend zehn sekunden nach 521
langsam wieder herauskommen okay das war
fitness am arbeitsplatz wie gesagt macht
das auszugsweise macht das gesamte werk
hat immer wieder einbauen ihr wird sehen
der körper reagiert darauf der dank
durch mit einer verbesserten haltung
schmerzfrei haltung und das ist ja das
um was es in wahrheit geht was ganz ganz
wichtig ist marlene hast du noch was für
unsere zuseher zu hause wie sollen sich
die fit halten im lockdown was ist dein
tipp ja ich würde gerne einfach sagen
bitte alle fit bleiben die zeiten sind
schwer aber irgendwann werden wir wieder
ins normale leben zurückkehren und ich
denke fitness schadet keinem schadet nie
und schadet keinem mit diesem statement
wo heute euch entlassen aus dem training
ja wohl dankeschön wir haben eine halbe
stunde fitness am arbeitsplatz mit euch
gut über die bühne gebracht morgen haben
wir einen spezialgast dabei einen
militärischen fünfkämpfer in korporal
mario seiser der wird im bereich
military fitness mit euch richtig gas
geben und wir freuen uns auf euch morgen
sei es dabei schaltet sein denn jetzt
mit bis morgen